foreign
bit of preparation that we do is all
about preventing a scenario happening in
the first place
[Music]
foreign
stay with your vehicle unless it is
dangerous to do so because with that
vehicle you've got a tremendous amount
of resources that you just cannot
physically carry on your back and it's a
bigger Target for search and rescue
[Music]
the first thing that I'd be doing if the
engine is still running is I would
switch off the engine you've got a
really big danger of carbon monoxide
poisoning if that exhaust pipe is
blocked you've literally got minutes
making yourself visible attracting
attention and trying to get assistance
would be most likely my next priority
stuff to keep the vehicle moving to to
begin with that's key so screen wash ice
scrapers a shovels it's better to try
and remove snow rather than just wheel
spinning your way through it
something to keep you warm so a rug you
know a blanket even better a very good
sleeping bag but I would also encourage
people to carry twice as much as what
they think they need because it's not
just about you it can be about other
people as well fluids definitely if you
are not hydrated you are more
susceptible to hypothermia and then you
know food to keep your energy levels up
as well and not just snacks let's
consider I mean people are being stuck
in their vehicle for two days
if they're saying don't drive then maybe
you should be questioning whether you
need to undertake that journey in the
first place and therefore we've you know
avoided a survival situation straight
away
foreign